et alors qu'en france on se prépare à
montrer patte blanche à l'entrée d'un
grand nombre de lieux publics en russie
la mesure a été levée dans la capitale
les moscovites n'ont donc plus à
présenter de qr code pour accéder au
restaurant au bar au club aux
discothèques la correspondance à moscou
devait rageman le coup de coeur n'est
plus moscou lève l'obligation de
présenter un certificat numérique à
l'entrée des restaurants et cafés
les autorités de la capitale explique
cette décision par la baisse du nombre
des hospitalisations ainsi que
l'augmentation radicale du nombre des
personnes vaccinées tout en
reconnaissant que la situation à moscou
reste compliqué je vous propose
d'écouter la situation à moscou demeure
compliquée néanmoins nous enregistrons
une amélioration des principaux
indicateurs depuis quatre semaines déjà
en comparaison avec les pics épidémiques
le nombre de cas de kobe de 19 détectés
chaque jour à pratiquement diminué de
moitié le nombre d'hospitalisations a
diminué d'un tiers
bien entendu cela a été rendu possible
grâce aux restrictions sanitaires
imposées ainsi qu'au renforcement des
mesures sanitaires et comme vous l'avez
fait remarquer à juste titre grâce à la
vaccination de masse le crâne soutient
la décision des autorités moscovites
selon dmitri peskov le porte parole du
président russe moscou a déjà prouvé son
efficacité dans la lutte contre
l'épidémie
écoutez les autorités moscovites ont
prouvé à plusieurs reprises leur
efficacité dans la lutte contre le
coronavirus le système de soins de santé
à moscou assez de potentiel pour
augmenter rapidement le nombre de lits
dans les hôpitaux pour intégrer
rapidement des réserves
je dirais que dans le cadre de la mise
en oeuvre de ces pouvoirs spéciaux des
autorités de moscou prenne cette
décision et je le répète encore une fois
moscou a déjà prouvé son efficacité et a
fait ses preuves dans la lutte contre
l'épidémie
nu les contaminations sont effectivement
baisse plus de vingt quatre mille
nouveaux cas de coronavirus ont été
détectés en russie ces dernières 24
heures dont près de 4000 à moscou
le nombre des décès est descendu à 719